"Пачками" на вибори. За різними оцінками,
з окупованих районів Донбасу було організовано понад 1400 рейсів
у Ростовську область для голосування на виборах до Держдуми Росії.
Щоправда, дехто навіть не розумів, що це парламентські вибори, а не президентські.
Буду голосувати за того, кого люблю - за Володимира Володимировича Путіна.
Автобуси з гаслами "Наш вибір - Росія".
В салоні - кожному по російському прапорцю в руку.
Оксана хизується на камери своїми паспортами:
Росії і так званої "ДНР".
Ми сподіваємося, що вступимо в Російську Федерацію.
- Як так сталося, що ви отримуєте паспорт і одночасно голосуєте?
Співпало за датами просто.
За різними оцінками, на окупованих територіях Донбасу
вже видали понад 650 тисяч російських паспортів.
Водночас, за словами секретаря РНБО Олексія Данілова,
темпи видачі паспортів сповільнилися, а українська влада
до цього питання буде ставитись дуже обережно і виважено,
розуміючи, що жителі окупованих територій змушені отримувати
російські паспорти, щоб працевлаштуватися й отримувати медичну допомогу.
Водночас щодо виборів до російської Держдуми лояльного ставлення
до учасників виборчого процесу на Донбасі та Криму
не буде, запевняє офіційний Київ.
Ми впевнені, що на цих територіях немає права
у Російської Федерації проводити вибори,
тому всі учасники цього процесу, які беруть участь,
члени виборчих комісій, агітатори, кандидати, всі спостерігачі,
які є офіційними особами на цих виборах, будуть під санкціями нашої країни.
Перший список тих, хто підпадає під санкції вже опрацьовано,
запевняють в РНБО. Під штрафні заходи потраплять й іноземні громадяни,
які брали участь у виборчому процесі на тимчасово окупованих територіях
як спостерігачі, навіть якщо вони політики чи посадові особи.
У Євросоюзі одностайно засудили проведення російських виборів
на окупованих територіях України.
Ми ніколи не визнаємо вибори в незаконно анексованому Криму,
бо Крим - це Україна. І ми також занепокоєні тим фактом, що громадянам України
та населенню з українських територій на сході, які зараз не перебувають
під контролем легітимного українського уряду,
видавали паспорти, щоб вони брали участь у цих російських виборах.
Це суперечить духу і цілям мінських угод.
І ми закликаємо Росію утримуватися від дій, які суперечать
зобов'язанням, прописаним у мінських угодах.
У Росії хизуються, що голосування, як вони кажуть
"громадян Росії на Донбасі", стало наймасштабнішим закордоном.
Окрім автобусних турів з окупованих територій Донбасу
на виборчі дільниці у Ростовській області, віддати свій голос
можна було і дистанційно. За попередніми даними,
онлайн проголосували понад 150 тисяч жителів ОРДЛО
з російськими паспортами.
Це було чітке послання з боку Росії
міжнародній спільноті, що ці території є частиною Росії
не формально, а на практиці.
Це наступний крок у війні проти України і в цілому Заходу.
Перед виборами людям видали десятки тисяч російських паспортів.
Коли я дивлюся на це, я не можу це назвати ніяк інакше як фальсифікацією.
Це не те, що Євросоюз будь-коли визнає.
Це неприкрита маніпуляція виборами,
абсолютно несумісна з міжнародними стандартами чесних, вільних та рівних виборів.
З цієї причини це неприйнятно
і не має нічого спільного з демократичними виборами.
Крім того, на Заході шкодують, що Росія не допустила
повноцінну місію Бюро з демократичних інститутів і прав людини ОБСЄ,
через що ця організація не змогла спрямувати спостерігачів
на вибори до Держдуми. За словами речника ЄС, ці вибори
відбулися в атмосфері залякування критичних і незалежних голосів
та без гідного довіри міжнародного спостереження.